c'est dans les années 70 que l'eau
courante a commencé à se généraliser à
la réunion auparavant les familles
allaient s'approvisionner à la fontaine
la plus proche transportant l'eau dans
des bacs en fer blanc les faits relatés
la matière et la v2 produite et rien ne
dit donc comme bape à l'adresse donnée
de lait nestlé
ces bacs en fer blanc était donc une
fois vide et réutilisées pour
transporter de l'eau mais aussi
transformer pour en faire des objets
utilisés chaque jour
le métier de ferblantier tenait dans
onenote et fransat est nettoyée avec ça
tu es fabrique manilow alain hippolyte
est l'un des quatre derniers ferblantier
de l'île de la réunion
son poste de travail un tronc de bois
ont établi et une poutre utilisé comme
siège
il exerce ce métier depuis l'âge de 14
ans c'est son grand père qui le lui a
transmis ses zaïla ont grimpé à la
dallas - bail doit avoir un bon 35 40
voilà mon grand père comme la veille
dans les 14 15 ans mais quand elle avait
11 ans même si le fer blanc en tant que
matière première n'existe plus 1-1 su
s'adapter
il utilise aujourd'hui de la tôle
galvanisée mais la méthode de
fabrication reste traditionnelle et
artisanale
maintenant le fer blanc là disparaître
donc nous la remplaçons la matière à
part la tôle galvanisée
parmi les quatre fermes entier de lille
j'anime à la chimie il exerce le métier
de professeur des écoles
mais consacrent la majeure partie de son
temps libre à sa passion c'est ici dans
mon travail parle et elle est à la fois
musée et elle l'a fait pour amuser les
devenu une passion et comme toute
passion connaît il prend énormément de
temps me direz tant lille n'est pas ce
qu'a fait implanter sa spécialité les
objets de décoration elle a une forte
demande aujourd'hui sur des objets de
décoration d'intérieur en fer-blanc
alors comme différents secteurs
galvaniser un travail aussi le zinc
réussi le cuivre mais principalement la
tôle galvanisée que la remplace le fait
à blanc dans les années 50 60
pour johnny bien que ce soit un métier
dit longtemps l'activité a de l'avenir
c'est un métier longtemps mais connaît
l'avenir
énorme à condition bien sûr d'aller
chercher des idées nouvelles des déchets
ce que le client il y attend et pour
durer dans le temps dans cette
génération robotisée le principal moteur
reste l'amour